Ok. In 1980.
After the first couple had come
to share the land. We met.
Some others who also were
looking for a place to live.
And build their place in their homes.
And we decided between ourselves.
Ok. They're the right sort.
They were sort of people we'd like to
share the land with. Let's invite them.
So we did so they became the
next the next layer of evil
and. Then there is people.
Members of family brothers
and eventually the parents.
Came.
So that it's a sort of set of
extended families in a way.
But basically it has to be.
People being invited by
the present members.
To come and live here
and not just a matter of of money
tens action like buying a share on
a property. Legally.
We had to live beyond the law as
it were for about eight years.
Which i must confess gave me.
Times when i was very concerned
and worried not only.
The possibility the risk
that was there always that.
Something could turn nasty and
the council might come and try
and bulldoze some of the
houses that had been built.
But also the feeling that.
I was technically still the chief
shareholder in the company
which owned the land
and all these people who had
come on our invitation.
Virtually were unprotected by the law.
And the assets that they had put in
the houses they'd built and the trees
that lined. Were technically not theirs.
Fortunately this never amounted
to anything i think other than
a bit of a worry on my part that.
Something unfortunate could happen
that way because by about nineteen eighty
six or seven i'm not quite sure which.
Coble council had at last.
Agreed to accept the possibility
of allowing multiple occupancies
in this particular corner
of their shire. Now they.
So once they were in a position to accept
multiple occupancies as a legal way of
use land use we were able to submit.
Applications for multiple occupancy.
This put them into slight.
Slightly awkward position because
there were already. Say.
Well many many more
houses built on the land.
Then were legally allowed
under the old scheme
but they had enough.
Gentleness
and sense to sort of a pointer
a very decent building
inspector who gave us.
Reasonable. Attention so that.
Although certain aspects of
most of the homes had to have.
Something done to them to bring them up
to his satisfaction and ordinance 70.
We didn't really suffer too much from
that side of complying with the
legal structure. So legally.
Each member of rob road
community has one share.
Has wondered.
And has the right to dispose of his
or her house. And general area.
Like garden private garden
that has been established only
to someone who is approved
by 100 per cent of the
rest of the community.
We have had one situation where
this is already happened.
It did pose a problem for this for the
people who wanted to move away because they
couldn't sell their thing. Their
house on the open market.
They couldn't ask as much as they
would have got on the open market.
And it took them. Much longer
probably than it would have this.
They had just left it on the open market.
But this is something we all agreed to
nisha lee that these are the conditions.
So that i mean that there are
some disadvantages in that sense.
This is not an investment.
It's a place to live in
that.
You know. Very high priority.
Yes it's very important to us that.
We we we've always tried
to put relationships among
community members. Absolutely.
At the top priority.
Doesn't matter about anything else
really. If your relationship.
Are good
and of course the longer
you can lives. And share.
This live beside each other and
share. The land or anything.
The longer you can do
that. Amicably. The more.
Easy it becomes so
that now i think there
is a very strong bond.
A bonding
that is sort of you know getting towards
something like you get between brothers
and sisters or family.
I hesitate to use
that word family because it's become
rather a potentially nasty label in some
communities isn't it. But it certainly.
Seems to work that. There's a good
deal of support for each other.
If somebody sick. Somebody. Well
when when anyone has a baby.
They the tradition has
become that they get.
A meal and evening meal prepared
and delivered for a fortnight
after the birth and we take it.
We just take it in turns to do that
and i mean that's that's
nothing but there's.
There's lots of other support sort of
awareness of each other and awareness of.
Shopping needs transport needs health.
It's it's it's very good.
Actually we share less and less now it's.
Ideally you know i must confess
that at first i thought community i thought
working side by side in the gardens.
You know producing things
and working together on projects be great.
Now we come together for social
reasons parties birthdays.
We come together to swim in our big dam.
In summer which is a lovely escape place.
We come together. On those unfortunate
occasions when we get aground so notice.
And all
and have to show some signs of doing
something to placate the rather.
In our minds rather absurd requests
to eradicate this plant that is.
Of of.
The potential danger to some people
or some graziers anyway.
We come together is is there
is a request to come together.
But we have a monthly
meeting to discuss various
business.
Usually attended by steps.
20 per cent maybe sometimes 30
40 per cent of the people but.
Very rarely that it's
everybody comes to meetings.
People change.
People.
Ah yes i do think that it's
changed over the years.
At first we did i think share an ideal.
Or a fantasy that you know we
would be working side by side
and we did have a community
garden going for a while
and it just.
It seemed not to be the way we as people.
Worked best as people moved
into their own homes.
Which was separate from each other they
found it was more successful more useful to
have their own gardens near their houses.
Then they could choose
what they wanted to plant.
They wouldn't have to go sort of
three hundred yards away carrying
that to lose it it has just generally.
Changed that that side of
things is very much chad.
And we used to run the shop for
ourselves. Come to think of it.
We had we we did weekly
purchasing we had bins full of.
Gosh.
So chickpeas we'd organic we'd of course.
We had a great week. Grinding meal because
we all made our own bread it's first.
Things changed. We've found that.
I. I think it was partly that. The
payment system we had a book.
We ended everything in. But there was
they really enough money in the kitty.
When we came to do the next lot of
purchasing not because anybody had been
dishonest or had it's just that
that wasn't convenient for
them to pay at the time so
that over a period of a couple of years of
trying to run these things for ourselves.
We decided that it just
would be easier at the.
That time to let it go. You know.
You.
Make.
I think we probably have
each come to our own assessment
of her own energy levels.
And have found that it's. More convenient.
To do things under our. Stay.
Rather than to try to
combine with each other.
The amount of energy needed to
organize say a shopping list among.
20 people each week to do the
purchasing two is to
distribute the product
and to get the pay back to get
the money for the next weeks.
All of
that energy just seemed to be too
much for any one person to take on.
So it has boiled down to each family seems
to have its own. Transport system anyway.
Has to go to the shops
some time during a week
or fortnight.
It just has boiled down to the fact that
each individual family now does it.
Does that side of things good self.
Mind you if we go to a major
crisis in the petrol supply.
Or a major shift in the whole
economic system so that.
There is a lot less money to go around
and a lot less petrol to go around.
I wouldn't be surprised if we wouldn't
be forced to get back into some sort of
system like that again.
So i can't say that it's due to personal.
Laziness or or.
Just failure of that idea or.
It's just the way things
that happened in our circumstances.
Yes.
Or is it really become
something.
At at my darkest moments were
just very often i used to think.
This is just another suburban.
Plot.
I think know that it's moved
beyond that. I think we've.
It's the community side of things
the support of each member for each
other member. Perhaps that
support isn't called for.
More than very occasionally but
when i was sort of where to go.
If you need something or if you need
a shoulder to cry on or if you need.
Some information for fixing something.
I think i think one of the
values in this community is
that you is enough range of skills. Sorry.
To.
The community can offer us. Yes.
It certainly is a feeling that
we want to support each other.
When anything happens to any individual.
There is there's of course is
support if anybody's sick or hurt.
Or if as occasionally happens
there are sort of relationship.
Problems or breakdowns. There's not.
There's not blame there's just support
for each individual because of course we
like each individual.
This is sounding like a
sunday school something.
Situation.
Personally i don't think
it does it may well be
that some some individuals think
that person ought to behave themselves in
which case it's it's their responsibility
to say that to that person
and not say to anybody else.
That this is something
that we've tried to.
Follow all along is if i have a grudge
against somebody else in the community.
Or if i think they're doing something i
don't like i have tried to say to myself
is this worthwhile just
accepting ok that's them.
That's the way they like to do things
or is it better for me to go to
that person and because they know
me i know them as a friend say.
I don't like that or why
are you doing that or i'm.
You wake me up in the mornings when you do
that. You know just to make each other.
Aware if there is something
that is irritating.
And then it's up to us
as individuals to work
that out between us what we try
to avoid and eyes. Think of.
Successfully is huge huge. Talking about.
That irritations caused by one person
talking about that to other people.
So that then it starts going
around and round in circles.
So i think that's one way that.
Perhaps we've tried to keep. Each other.
Aware of where we're
possibly going against
another soul in the community. I guess.
A stable population so.
Yes. Yes it has had this
fairly stable population.
Although there have been people who
have moved away for. Very good reasons.
There hasn't been any big blow ups
or any sort of emotional strife
that seems to have caused people
to move away. They've moved away.
For economic reasons
or for health reasons.
One of the challenges. You know.
So.
Yes to be economically
sustainable is is quite a.
A mouthful isn't it. It's quite a a
and that cheeseman i guess we've.
Ideally we wanted that to be happening.
It's taken much longer than i ever
hoped never thought it would but.
I think that it's. It's been happening.
Over the last several years now
that people have become more and more.
Independent of any form
of government support.
There is still a few people on
the place who are pensioners
or unmarried mothers or you know.
Single parents with on welfare. But.
On the whole most of the craft people
and the musicians have found
which is that they can work in
that will bring in a viable income.
So although it's taken longer than
i'd hoped or with all hoped. It.
It is happening and it's i think.
Another another sort of effect of
not having to pay rent of having
a reasonably adequate. Sort
of. Place to live in. Now.
Each family seems to have built
their own home gradually
taking a long time and with a lot of
effort since none of them was you know.
A qualify builder to begin with.
But now they've each got a reasonably
comfortable and sound place to live in.
Which is without a mortgage and
without no overhead costs.
So that
that in itself helps to make it possible to
make a living out of either the kraftwerk
or the music. To show.
Sure. So.
I think. You know person. Oh really.
I would have you know really
well i would i've been there
but. Sometimes yes yes. Oh
there are cliches sage.
Yeah. That. I tell you. Bruce mcnichol
be a good one to talk to about that.
Do you know him as a he is a musician and.